[Music]
hello everyone welcome to Google AI
huddle
thank you so much for for being here and
thank you to everyone who volunteered
earlier to rearrange all the chairs we
had a different set up which wouldn't
have worked out so everyone who did that
and really appreciate that thanks a lot
how many of you are here for the first
time okay roughly half of the crowd so
right I mean basically you know
googly-eye huddle is an open
collaborative and developer first AI
forum and our goal is it driven by AI
Googler expertise and the goal is to
have AI conversations out in the open
right no strings attached you can come
in have you know pizza and how the AI
conversations talk through your problems
and discuss you know things you know
which you have blocked on how do you see
we can help you with your AI workload
and you know sort of enable enable AI in
your business and whatnot additionally
we also have what we are calling a
huddle office hours and office hours are
away for it's still in pilot but it's a
way for you to literally hop on a
hangout VC conversation and talk to a
Googler right so I think I think that's
that's a great thing and again you know
no strings attached it's all is free of
course and our goal really used to learn
as much as we can from you to really
understand what your pain points are and
and how AI can enable you and how we can
enable you with that I'll hand it over
to Shantanu hey all I'm Shanthi no I'll
eat that cloud AI user research team and
also responsible for data analytics and
IOT so one of the missions that we are
on in the user research so basically
what we do is we bring insights from the
field back to the product teams and so
this channel is a great source for us
because you guys you can
connect with us tell us about your
problems so basically we'll get into
details about your problems through
office hours through forums like this
and also we have like an hour or so
before and after this session for you to
network with us so my goal personally
selfish goal here is to gather all the
pinpoints that you have hopefully we can
turn those pain points into product
features and eventually solve your
problems so that's how I'm involved in
this effort how many of you use
notebooks and curious okay great awesome
fantastic so Slava who I work closely
with is gonna be covering notebooks
today specifically with DCP in mind oh
okay you want me to do the intro okay
okay all right
okay yourself about this okay so I'll do
this quickly so slow is a Google cloud
AI tech lead with seven plus years of
experience working on deep learning
images for Google Cloud II i teaching
java courses blogging about deep
learning and tensorflow basically making
things work he also has a link on the
meetup event page so feel free to check
out his link and about his work more
than anything is just a great guy that's
why we partnered with him and focus on
his team and we saw a lot of interesting
problems every day order you thank you
everyone
yeah my short name is Slava that is my
full name over there yeah and before we
begin there was already several
questions asked but they still would
like to ask several more just understand
what the what you guys are using
day-to-day basis so you already guys
answer about notebook now the question
who is using Google cloud okay some part
of the audience who have heard about our
product is the data lab or deep learning
VMs okay one hand only one hand okay but
someone okay now
this talk is about so yeah why I'm going
to just discuss with the main audience
while you guys have time to open Twitter
and just follow me with that particular
tag but while you guys doing this I'm
going to discuss coda one is for this
talk so there are many audiences people
who using Jupiter lab on day-to-day
basis with a big in in the team not just
by yourself as one one team member per
team if you if you're using Jupiter
notebook for a small project that you're
working on your own as a scribe pook
probably these practices not going to
resonate with you but if you use it if
you have tried to use notebook with a
bigger team with
virtual control system you probably know
how painful is so we're going to start
the talk with Jupiter the notebook
development manifesto manifesto is
basically a collection of small
theoretical rules or some suggestions
that you guys can use but the thing is
the key part here that this is just the
statement there is no easy recipe how to
convert this statement to a nice nice
best practice that you can apply in this
topic I'm going to show some of them
some recipes that you can come home and
actually try to apply with your team but
the key here that this is more concept
something that you need to try to aim
and several ideas how you can do some of
the things already today there is no
silver bullet exists right now on the
market different players trying to
tackle the solution for nice
collaborative notebooks in their in
their ways and we're going to see how
Google actually solving this problem
this talk effectively featuring one
article that was published with
effectively this manifesto and github
repository github repository is the
source that not only has manifesto but
also has some tools that already been in
the developed that can help to enforce
some of the ideas behind the manifesto
so let's force first walk step by step
which each of the statement and then we
can jump to actual implementation so
statement number one
Jupiter notebook is effectively just the
tool and there's any tool you as a
software engineer do need to use all the
best practices that applies to software
develop the process this is a simple
statement but it's actually been ignored
on the in a wild drastically and we will
try to figure out why today second one
Jupiter notebook needs a version control
system integration it's not so right now
if you've tried to put your notebook at
the gate you know probably how horrible
disease how to do a code reviews for
Jupiter notebooks
horrible to the knowledge conflicts it
just does not work the serpent
gbto notebook should be absolutely self
100% self-contained we will see why and
what this can give us there should be a
way to pass input arguments to the
jupiter notebooks and this is actually
give us a powerful way to create things
from the item number five
each jupiter notebook should be checked
by Cugini system integration and the
last one before we're going to dive each
notebook effectively should be plugged
into a continuous development system and
each artifacts produced by the notebook
if it's passing particular minimum goal
of your team or your product should be
deployed to the production the same as
you will do with any other software now
all this effectively these on the github
you can go and check the tools that
already exist you can actually try to
propose some changes if you see a typo
or tarawa now in this talk we're going
to cover the first three item more or
less in depth with some what we'll call
double cover item number four and number
five and unfortunately it's completely
out of scope number six as of today
conversation there are actually PZero
priority zero that is not there formally
but it should be there should be a way
for the very easy way to use jupiter not
this is probably the first that we're
going to cover and then we'll jump the
first one two and three so if you on the
google cloud I'm going to stab to walk
you through the solution that we have
and how we tackling this particular
problem how to make use of the Jupiter
lab very simple for our customers how
many of you guys have heard about Google
co-op okay slightly more than about deep
learning via that is mmm not a
surprising useful but as ATL of deep
learning VMs not a happy news as well
okay so let me speak about this the
solution and how they are different we
effectively already have
co-op which is really simple way to
start using
notebooks and if you haven't sync up let
me try really quick just open it co-op
oh I don't see my my my mother's okay
never mind I've tried I've tried so let
me compare this the institution if
you've never seen co-op before just I
would encourage you to go and try and
search just Google co-op co-op
collaboratory Google so what are the
difference of activity between these
these two tools now let's first speak
about the collaboratory the nice part
about coop is first to start you're
actively getting absolutely 100% managed
environment that can be start within a
second you just opening a browser you
can start using your your notebook
you're getting for free one GPU which is
nice you have k80
you're getting for free one GPUs yes
it's not the latest TPU but still it's
free and it's a CPU you now have amazing
collaboration experience where several
people can edit the same notebook a kind
of thing the way how would you envision
the Google Documents work now this is a
process obviously is any product there
are some cons and collaboratory doesn't
give you any persistence so if you
working with a notebook your VM going to
be recycled each 12 hours or some amount
of hours this effectively means that if
install your customer packages is going
away
you're also not able to start any long
term training because your VM going to
be recycled it's not possible these more
resources whatever we give it to you
that's it you cannot attach 96 skylight
cores or two GPUs or a GPUs or whatever
there is no versioning support which
means you cannot say I need ten the flow
one month ten or I don't so I don't know
pi torched 0.4 there is no integration
with version control system and no nice
integration with GCB and last but not
least raw right now in the production
support 2 main framework tender for
Python and the factory that is it now if
all these cons acceptable for you let's
say you are one one person T
that develops using notebook as a
scratch pad you probably do need to
stick to club I would highly recommend
that indeed if the collapse is a tool
that you can use you should be using now
the second product that we have is
effectively product several products
built around the planet VM which is when
your Jupiter lab on the Google cloud pro
so this stop stop persistence you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
if you if you're creating it VM it will
save whatever we have that if you're
starting packages it's not going to be
recycle everything at that it has
integration with it flexibility of the
research resources we will see how you
can easily edit it at a GPU idiot a GPU
do whatever you want
that's nice GCP integration and finally
we're showing you can specify which
particular version turns off already
now the cons it's not free you need to
pay like we cannot give you a to be 100
GPU for free even for a short period of
time now
collaboration feature is not supported
that is also something that Jupiter lab
as a community trying to solve but it's
not there
and finally time to start the slightly
hard because you actually need to stop
VM now among this product we're going to
focus on the Jupiter lab mostly because
it's very simple to integrate different
best practices to this particular
solution and Before we jump into
different other item from manifesto let
me show how quickly and simple is
actually to create one of the VM because
all other examples will be on the DL so
this is how creation process looks like
did you do let me play a quick video
this is effectively cloud marketplace
one of let me open cloud marketplace one
of our products on the Google cloud if
you type there deep learning VM you will
find with this this solution on the
marketplace and spam the VM is simple
you click in lunch then you effectively
specifying all the configuration that
you want configuration the name just put
something meaningful for you something
that you will know why you created this
VM one VM is effectively you can think
of
one VM is one Jupiter lab instance that
allows you to run many many different
notebooks okay this would be PI touch
playground you specifically you can
specify zone it should be obviously as
close to you as possible and the Machine
type with the amount of CPUs on top of
this you can specify how many and what
type of GPUs you can use let's let's
pick P 100 and the framework I will
pause here just for a moment so these
are the framework that we're supporting
that's a flow several addition tells a
fall to the toy is just experimental
mode inside will ready pre-baked several
interesting deep learning courses that
been built around and the flow to the
doll actually was surprised that there
are actual deep learning courses already
around tensorflow to the top
we do have pi touch with past the eye
with pasta occurs pre-built by actually
supporting students of past the eye we
have change extra boost MX net and for
base images base images is effectively
just in images that has everything you
might need to start using GPU if you
have I don't know open CV compiled in
the way that capability lies in GPU and
you want to run it somewhere you need
Nvidia driver if you need cooter you
need to do an end or maybe coup blocks
or something else there is not much
reason not to use base image if you're
planning to use GPU just because you
will have to install everything that
there yourself
okay so let's pick something in this
particular example PI torch now this is
a feature that we just have announced
effectively because of the DM as soon as
you create a VM you need to be able to
access it to run your to see a Jupiter
lock this better feature effectively
will give you a link
nice-nice link that you can open in
browser that link would check your
identity whether you have access to this
particular GPS all up or not and if you
do it will proxy all the traffic to
actual vm that you have created the just
a nice touch that all of you to access
vm after the creation and really easy
way and obviously need to install the
driver okay so this is effectively the
more or less the creation part then you
need to wait and this is reason why it's
video because i
[Music]
make it I think 20 feet for this
creation because it's it's slow
unfortunately yes it would be it would
be really really slow to show it
real-time in the end of the creation you
will get one particular comment
executing which will give you a link as
soon as you have this link now you no
longer need to do anything you can just
add it to favorites or whatever so here
is a link and just the showcase that we
do have running Jupiter I'm going to
open this link this is your Jupiter so
that is it you have fully worked Jupiter
on the cloud with P 100 GPU under the
hood there is some tutorials already
pre-baked in this particular case this
is Python so there is a pass the eye and
just to make sure that GPU is actually
accessible media semi to show that we
have T 100 so everything works as
expected video driver there okay so this
is simplicity this is how you actually
can I'm going to run the whole notebook
how you can actually access Jupiter
notebook on the GCP so we have covered
this part priorities you let's speak
about the tooling the item number one
will be more conversational and rest of
the item will be more practical so just
the two what does it mean let's say
you're speaking with Android developer
and you ask an Android developer who
came to you on the interview who wants a
position in team you're asking what are
the best software engineering practice
like CI and CD or something on base that
you have used on your project and
suddenly the person tells you oh no no
no that is different like we Android
developers we don't using all this like
what are you going to tell such person
probably okay it's nice answer will call
you by right but suddenly this strange
conversation somehow makes sense for
Jupiter love everyone whom you asking
about Jupiter notebook will tell you no
we're not using it like we're not using
sorry I'm not using CD we don't have
tests around our notebook
we don't have any right because we are
different in
see this is just the tool there are some
practices did a specific form droid lab
or Android studio that is for sure
because it's XML because it's UI but
similarly there are some best practices
for Jupiter laughs it doesn't mean that
if they have custom practices you cannot
apply generic software developer
practices any Android app should have
the ICD was test any Jupiter love that
you committing to the source code system
should also have this now unfortunately
there is no best practices tooling
around on the market that is why a lot
of the people are forced to use Jupiter
lab or Jupiter notebooks at a scratch
pad I've hearing this again and again
from many developers when they
prototyping they having a notebook they
prototyping in a notebook but then
because notebook as a tool is not ready
for production or use they rewriting the
code usually when you're speaking when
you're diving deeper to the problem
you'll see that no one wants to rewrite
the code from notebook to actual Python
because it's consumes a lot of time and
it's actually something that you don't
need to do you have to do because you
don't have tooling around now there are
some cases when you actually just using
Jupiter notebook as scratch pad that is
for sure
the same how I for instance have many
pets projects on the Android and a lot
of Python on my local laptop that I not
covering with the I not covering with
tooling for that particular cases you
can use call up collabo is perfect
solution for that use cases if you don't
need anything except one notebook with
Google Drive for just experimenting
probably also don't need too much
ressources under the hood co-op is a
deal to so this is the idea on the high
level behind I would hide the mentality
that this is just a tool now the second
part
effectively all at the part if you look
on this this is just
extensions of the item number one second
part is version control system usually
when we're saying now the expression
control system was speaking about get
not many people using mercurial
and I hope almost no one using SVN
nowadays or or before so let me show you
exact problem and what what the solution
might be for this particular political
element so let me start with the problem
here is a notebook notebook on Japan
aquarium notebook inside of the get I'm
going to execute two cells and from my
perspective I have not added this
notebook it's perfectly fine right now
there is I have not changed anything but
the notebook by itself adjacent file
that has some metadata inside under the
hood a lot of stuff have changed
for instance you now have this number
one you now have star on the second cell
then you will have number two the second
cell and if you're actually going to go
and get client we do have some good
client integration you will see that
this file has been modified already okay
let's assume you're coming back to this
file after after week after a vacation
you see that this file being modified
you want to see if you need to check in
to commit this file right you see that
somehow be modified and normal reaction
to go and see it if let let me see it
see food what have I done with that
particular file
what have I changed do I need to commit
it or maybe not
it says that file that modified and now
it's now let's see what's what's D for
showing us and here is the DV from my
perspective actually they cannot change
anything in the notebook but from
perspective for the notebook there are a
lot of stuff that have changed and if
you know how internally everything works
maybe you can guess but maybe not and
this is just a small change if I would
do if I were to execute several more
cells you will have a bigger bigger and
more horrible deep lying around okay so
how this can be improved inside of the
github repository that I showed in the
beginning when I mentioned that
Manifesta actually have some of the
tools we already have some preset of the
tools that help to improve deep learning
vm experience we're going to work on
the planning maybe someone want to to
improve it and adopt some other some
other frame environments but as of now
it works only our diploma creams so it's
effectively a small script I go on the
github repository that comes with this
talk you will have the link video slides
I'm going to run just a small scrip
scrip that enables get integration again
it's now has turned 10x speed because it
will take time to integrate everything
in dip learning vm that we need as soon
as done it's going to reboot Jupiter lab
this is okay now let's see what have
happened in the end now who opening this
same notebook and what have changes is
to small icons these to small icons on
top one with small get icon and clock
like icon effectively it's one of the
plugins that allow you to do a really
nice and amazing things all of you to do
a normal difficulty of the notebooks
here is a normal deep which effectively
shows on the left hand side or the same
cell that in was empty now in this one
then the second cell the same image to
nothing have changed it has this blue
item showing the deep of the metadata
but that's it it's actually normal deep
we do have also integration of even
margining and conflict resolution for
the different notebooks for the
different notebooks one more example of
the d4 with more complex situation can
look like this so this is just a
teaching of the notebook again on top of
did the justin normal teaching tool
executed on deep learning vm that shows
you normal normal different okay so this
is how we can enforce one of the item
from best practices this is again just
link for the github with manifest and
tools now search sort item do be the
notebook should be self-contained and
first let me show what possible to do if
your notebooks is self-contained so
let's say yeah let's let's start it
usually with the exam
let's say you prototyping your notebook
suddenly you have decided to do a GPU
because you don't want to pay money for
GPU
so you want to detach it right now it
looks like this you're going to be an
instances all your instances are there
and there are probably many of them I
pick one of the chunk who is a lot a lot
of instances now in order to find it you
probably need to go back to your
deployment to figure out the name of
your instance by touch one playground
find it here you're ready spending some
time now you can edit instance but in
order to edit instance you need to stop
it stopping text time again I have 10x
rewind here after style after full stop
you finally can edit it you can edit
them you need to find where is the GPU
for me it always takes time to find
where exactly in the Edit this GPU are
yeah after the editing I will scroll
this because it's not too fun you can
actually start it again after the
editing and the start process actually
takes also some time I have 10 10x here
for starting because it's also take time
and after your start that you have a GP
so this video by itself is one and a
half minutes in reality I actually timed
it and I have it the next slide in
reality takes 4 minutes approximately 4
minute to stop edit start now let's say
you attach GPU you executing your
training finally you see a back
you see barking when you need to debug
this bug while you debugging you don't
want to pay for your GPU so we need to
detach you need to prototype you need to
attach back and start the training so
effectively one buck requires two more
edits which is plus eight minutes so you
can see it's actually waste of time
especially if you have different box you
need to iterate I mean it's good if we
if the company pays for your resources
to don't care you can just attach a GPU
and forget about it but if you actually
paint from your pocket this might be a
nightmare now what would be really nice
to have let's assume that you
prototyping or you deploy
um that is laptop with the user behind
this laptop I don't know let's call him
Bob so the Bob prototyping country's
laptop using deep learning VM under the
hood would be nice when needed when you
actually want to train to spin up
another something
another instance like deep learning VM
that actually has GPUs that small tiny
icons that looks like exactly like a DM
icons it's official icon of GPU yeah and
it looks exactly the same as icon for 40
VM itself but trust me GP ok so now you
want to spin up a GPU machine execute
the training there and then give give
result back and destroyed that back-end
machine that look really nice you you
paint only for train a but in order to
do so because that second entity if even
if it's deep learning VM it doesn't have
any knowledge about your environment
your environment that you have used for
prototyping might be completely
different you might have done something
something strange there in order for
this unit of work you need the notebook
that actually self-contained and even
better if you if you have a
self-contained notebook it might work
through the control source controls
source repository system like it you can
push it and then deploy Nick VM can pull
it to build it test it and destroy it so
let me actually show how it works
already again you can find the tooling
for this on the same wrapper so let's
say I have some some notebook I'm going
to actually download notebook with our
git integration from from just github
just the random tensorflow notebooks I
spent some time trying to find here a
meanest
amidst example let me scroll this
because I wasn't sure which folder it is
yeah so here is a nice notebook that
that I finally finally have found and I
want to take this they want to train
this with GPU my local machine is CPU
and I want to send it on the background
training while I can continue
time in order to do so I'm going to
install the second script from the same
repository it's again we'll do a special
magic yeah we're going to the same repo
it showed the showed before going to
planet I mean the qualms not going to
folder responsible for self contained
non books and there is a script enable
notebook submission again as of now it's
working on your deep learning VM not on
all the Jupiter instances but this is
yeah this can be changed now now let's
go to the folder that contains my
notebook that I actually want to execute
I know the folder I just copy it and if
everything is done right you now have
two CLI commands that are available to
your just to your to your usage let me
show you that the comments yeah these
are the two commands execute notebooks
with CPU or with GPU there are four
input arguments to this comment one is
name of your notebook another one is
Google Cloud storage temporary bucket
and for CPU data zero that is all that
is all you need to provide for GPU
comments you also need to specify type
of GPU and amount of GB in my case as I
said I want to train this notebook and
in the background with GPU so I'm using
execute notebook with GPU then as I just
mentioned they provided name of the
notebook then I have some pre-populated
Google Cloud storage you need to be sure
that your VM has access to that storage
this is storage V 101 so I do want to
train with one v 100 that is effectively
what is happening right now it's
uploading everything to GCS starting
p.m. starting the training this is again
fast reboot each 10 seconds I'll show
you there is a small error in there and
just because script as of today just
checking if this background VM actually
exists and the error means that it's no
longer exist mean it means that
trainings have succeeded and the VM has
self-terminate itself and the result
being applauded to GCS as of today
alt notebook has named surprise surprise
notebook dot I PI and D it's always
notebook I pine B and this is a notebook
you can see on the Left panel that it's
created a second ago because it was
downloaded from our background
background VM and it's fully populated
so all the cells are there is actually
have executed everything and this is
effectively one the order of the
recognition and the training actually
happened to live a hundred on the
background so you're going to pay only
for a time of women hundred that you
have used for training if something has
crashed you will see crash here you can
restart your notebook here with CPU you
can prototype again when you're ready
you can go to your console you can
submit your notebook to the background
train but as I said it should be
self-contained
okay so we have discard this and just to
to show on the on the diagram what has
happened we have one VM we effectively
applauded our notebook to cloud storage
we have spin up deploy nerium everything
script is doing for you that deep
learning vamp has downloaded your script
then we're using technology that has
named paper mill that was developed by
Netflix paper mill is basically special
open-source tool that is in charge of
executing notebooks locally without any
any UI interface attached and as soon as
these succeeded we've done the hooks
little through cloud storage back and
destroyed the backend bail that is
pretty simple a pretty important work
now we always were saying that you need
self-contained notebooks let's speak
about what exactly this means what
self-contained means several things same
number one you need to have notion about
which deep learning VM like 10 0 M 20
you have used for creating notebook our
deep learning VM has already tons of
different different packages very likely
you will not need to install anything
else you can use CENTAC a non pipeline
that started learn tons of them already
there but they have different
so you need to make sure that the
notebook has information that it was
created with M 19 M 18 in this way we
can spin up exactly the one declaring me
M that has exactly the same set of
packages and the version this is number
one number two is simple if you do need
any dependency please use magical cell
inside of the notebook that install them
that's it I mean I don't understand that
there are some cases when it's actually
not practical there are tons of
dependency and magic cell could be a
huge in this case we do have several
other ways but in many cases you would
be surprised deep learning VM already
have majority majority of the things you
need you can just install two packages I
don't know maybe you need MX net for
some reason you can install it already
just use the magic so that is it it's
actually pretty simple
now limitations current limitations of
this particular script the solution
itself can be extend all these
limitations can be solved but current
limitations becoming home if you're
going to actually use the street with a
do planning M there are some of current
limitations and actually many other
right now only works with telephone vm's
we do have PI torch memes but this this
is not going to work yet only works on
CLI I personally would be would be
thrilled to see a nice button you
pressing the button it magically got
there and then magically come back but
for now it's on the CLI third one always
uses latest answer flow yes I know I
have told you like moment ago you need
to know which particular version but for
now it's ignore it it always will use
terms of call a test even if it were
created not with the latest for now it's
not capable of catching files around the
notebook again it's not a problem you
can upload your local folder to Google
Cloud storage and downloaded and for the
backend VM it's just current
implementation is not capable using
files and artifacts lying around not yet
possible to pass any input arguments and
this is actually very important but here
is a link to github please do feel free
to contribute fix like pick any of these
and solve it if you
you happens if one of them actually
creates more pain than another for you
now next item that we will just going to
cover so so without diving too much its
input argument and why this is important
and this is almost almost last of my
slides this is example from one of
previous notebooks we actually don't
care what notebooks is doing but it has
number of steps number of steps is
something that reasonably you want to
change you might want to test with much
different batch sizes different number
of steps different learning rates it's
something that you want dynamically to
adjust when I say that notebook should
have ability to process input I mean
that you should be able to override
these variables from outside of the
notebooks without changing not
this is powerful concept that again
paper mill and Netflix has implemented
already that script that I that I have
used doesn't have the support but with
this particular ability to write these
variables you can actually implement
through continuous integration system
imagine notebook but when you sending
this notebook to the get continuous
integration system pulls this notebook
oval writes variables for example it's a
writes name of the table and instead of
the production table it's using table
with mock small amount of data and
executing everything with that small
amount of data just to verify that the
notebook is working completely working
and if something is broken its pages
whoever is on call or whoever's charge
of the build oh this is possible if you
do integrate this capability of input
arguments so this is effectively covers
the last two and why it's important to
have a deal easy to pass input argument
to notebooks and this guy effectively if
you're solving number four number five
with technicality this is actually wall
so this is five elements or if we're
counting zero six elements we have not
covered the last one as I said this part
the otoscope just to recap just to
mention this is more an item that you
should aim for github has script that
will help you already to import them but
don't think about that it hop is a
production of solution that you can just
you there will be a lot of problem but
it will give you some flavor of how
future the notebooks might look like and
that is all thank you very much guys
let's move to a question question QA
create part if there is any question
thank you oh we have a question let can
can someone help with passing the mic so
I guess yeah it could be a silly
question but can you compose notebooks
can you include one notebook in another
and then run run it capability okay yeah
just just want to mention there is no
like silly question there's only silly
answers but yes so question was if I can
use one book and another one somehow yes
okay I mean you cannot with vanilla
notebook you do need to install several
plugins of paper meal or something that
allows this capability but there are
several solution on the market already
that effectively allows you to say
something I need variable a from the
notebook blah and it will execute
notebook blah until a is populated and
then will import a so that is already
possible yeah that is actually there are
even though technically solvable it's
open question about best practices
whether this is recommended way or not
my personal take on this that if you
using generalized logic it's better
generic logic to be just a pure Python
if you want with just imports but
technically is used to can import one or
another thank you any other questions
yep
can you please close the mic yes sorry
because with microphone you guys will be
recorded
so you are talking about tests so you so
you are saying that if we can input
parameters like we can just change the
table name or some part of the table
name and then we can read like Mach
table names and so it's your vision that
there's those table the test tables yeah
will be sort of automatically generated
or you are envisioning something that
you have to create a table and then the
test case is you for the rows that you
want to test you how to write it because
that's pretty painful and if you have a
lot if you have two tables you just can
create the more table table otherwise it
will be kind of hard to create tables
like with all the edge cases
what's your original testing because in
general testing programs were used to it
yep bar testing that process data the
logic the data logic we are not used to
it in the data industry right kind of
yes so how do you ambition that so okay
your questions actually are absolutely
right if you're going to manually mock
the database it might be kind of painful
so there are two things here first of
all for notebooks usually the simple
space let me first the say one more
thing so you have usually most popular
you need tests and functionalists right
for notebooks is harder to do unit tests
simpler to the function test when I ran
the whole notebook now in this
particular example that I show to you
just writing input variable will force
you to create yourself manually a table
which is which is horrible but this is
just the first step the second step is
you can can have a normal Python test
that will generate data then it that
will call training on that data and will
and will check the result
I have not showcase here the actual CI
but CI that we that we have for demo
actually doing like this so because it's
it's not just deployed deploying
background training kits for generated
data deploys background training and
checks that the artifact that notebooks
submitting actually
has a results from that thing just to
make sure that that is working what is
we right now definitely missing is
ability to go even deeper and do for
instance unit tests like particular
style that you can start that part
correct yes that part will be harder but
but yes it's possible
any other questions so you the winning
of the talk you were mentioning date
Allah
but you didn't show it
oh yeah I asked if someone knows
build-up so effectively yeah indeed I
have to show it and one of the reasons
because you can see you can think about
depending a.m. solution is data latitude
okay so it's that's all right there
somewhere deep learning vm's know they
they allow me to know the solution deep
learning is is by itself a data lab with
you so that's reincarnation it's not yet
as parity in the features that's why you
will not find this statement yet that's
a question okay good but at some point
it would have parity of the features
plus other features great thank you
anything else
okay then thank you guys have a nice
evening
[Applause]
[Music]